we're gonna die we're gonna die I got
research thinking today what up fellow
gangsters car is here I'm gonna have to
be really quick
it's the day off today as well mein
YouTube life is hard
we're going to a museum and Griffith
Observatory let's go we decided to make
a quick shopping stop because we like
the street so we're doing that
joining at this
it's me oh we're gonna die we're gonna
die
I got a research thing in today okay so
now I can go from hipster to la hipster
I was definitely worth 20 bucks got a
smoothie let's try this out really good
mmm
I spent like an hour this morning
planning out what we're gonna do we've
done nothing of what we planned so far
yeah oh now we're having lunch we'll see
what happens after okay we're finally
going to what we were supposed to be
doing today no more damn shopping all
right okay we made it Museum of dead the
outside looks cool at least
alright looks legit
whoa oh my god that's so cute oh my god
yeah two-headed turtle wait don't sell
me I'm not gonna bother about love
certain one head to head
that's weird I'm not a fan of that place
at all that was just [ __ ] up and weird
would not recommend a rosin sing-along
no no no a giant chair why not time to
relax
Oh mom relaxing time for a fashion show
Bres I have something to tell you the
24th of September it's the launch of
legend of the brofist I'm gonna show you
a new level
legend of the brofist whoo once you beat
on all the difficulties which is really
hard
there is also pakka mode where you can
place my own Edgar I didn't even know
this I'm Edgar no again
uh alright let's play as Peter pine
classic marks here goddamn it I suck so
bad at my own game it's sad let's
activate the brofist yeah take that
[ __ ] duck mode this is the greatest
game of our ten in six days you bros
will be able to play this game it's
gonna be giveaways there's gonna be
livestream rewards if you beat beat
certain levels first so be sure to be
ready when the game comes out because
you will get some exclusive stuff but
that's all for today
views are up this month look estimated
minutes watch the [ __ ] is that well it's
for me alright let's open it together
I love package F they loved tape to me
tell me how jelly you are feel free to
tell me I was just gonna say though how
grateful I am for doing what I'm doing
here I feel like I'm truly living life
everyday here in LA because it's so much
fun like I'm only having fun I don't
have to worry about videos as much cuz
I'm vlogging I can just do what I want
to do and it's amazing and it's all
thanks to you bros and it seems that the
vlog has kind of put more life into the
channel as well so I'm just so happy
about it it's [ __ ] amazing it really
is all thanks to you bro so thank you
for watching the vlog I don't know why
people care cuz it's not like I'm doing
anything extraordinary but I'm having a
lot of fun with it I am NOT going to
vlog forever though this vlog boot will
expire for two reasons number one I'm
just gonna do it while I'm here in LA
number two when you see people who's
done daily vlogs for like years
they look so down
on it it you can tell the fun of daily
vlogging is just sucked out of them I'll
do it as long as it's fun but I swear to
God if if it's not fun I will not do it
and so far I plan to stop once I get out
of LA to enjoy it while it lasts bros
we're waiting for PJ and Sophie some
friends from UK to come over oh my god
guys they're here
oh no that's someone I don't know who
this is swedish fish we have these in
sweden obviously well we just call them
fish we have using liquorice - there oh
but I actually can't show what's in the
box
I know it's lame right are you getting
tired of this cuz it will spoil who I'm
working with and I know for sure I can't
do that
oh my god okay stop eating the fish
wrong door save okay there you go
action I found them hey we're gonna eat
Chinese food yes I love Chinese food we
ordered the Great Wall
let's all begin at 1 3 2 yeah
destroy this wall it's a tall wedge
because what you do
it's chocolate movie magic happening in
LA he likes does all of his own stuff
it's true have we're going back we're
gonna play board games cuz we're with PJ
and Sophie yeah I think that's been a
pigeon Sophie gave me an amazing gift
okay it's the government right I don't
know if you guys know but I'm kind of a
big deal I know I never seen these
before
this is not the cover no oh there yeah
it's like the same I'm not a cover I
know it is is that how it was I don't
know well I'll take it yeah
do you miss that haircut may God's gift
I think this one's for you oh thank you
and this one is for Marcia we did voice
acting for Oscars Hotel what that's
awesome oh this is the theme of this
yeah this is the [ __ ] I like a good
choice of thing Oscars Hotel t-shirts
hey guys
ladies feel cool what is it guys if I'm
done that's a that's is that the
official banana that's an illegitimate
not home hey bra there's my character in
the show the reason I love so much is
because I told ya to make beats yeah
they're very cluttered that they're
Berrian very cool my I never seen March
this legit
for like you would know well it's yeah
it's what is super Sophie no everyone
Sophie just broke herself okay there we
go box transition band anything what's
it like
hold on camera Renaud looks like I won
thank you hang up will hold all right
the doors over there PJ would you
recommend legend of the brofist this is
the worst game I've ever played good but
let's hug on camera oh I got that on
camera feel like this would be a lot
better if I had a hat
Oh mr. moose this is another vlog
finished as always
I'll just see you tomorrow and we'll do
other weird [ __ ] all right as always
thanks for watching stay awesome ruff
80% of my time in LA has been spent so
far look guys man I gotta tell ya
vlogging is hard